some African wild dogs are feasting on
their latest kill and where the
possibility of leftovers exists here in
Africa's Serengeti
so do opportunistic griffon vultures
and right below Bulger's on the
scavenging totem pole there's the star
of this adventure the white neck Raven
the cunning Raven is thinking ahead it
goes where it thinks fresh meat will
soon be in the midst of the expectant
wild dog cuts sure enough this dominant
female arrives with you'll excuse the
pun a doggy bag for her young the raven
can't compete with the vultures at the
scene of a carcass but maybe it can
snatch a quick bite from the messy wild
dog puffs you think the Raven gets a
scrap but the pups keep chasing the
Raven off before it gets a bellyful
still hungry and frustrated the raven
decides to bug the Griffon vulture
but alas there's no honor among thieves
the Raven doesn't give up you have to
admire its persistence even as you
acknowledge the lack of results yeah
okay that didn't work maybe bothering
this giant lappet-faced vulture will get
it to share is this a good idea no not
really
the wild dogs spread the worst party's
over
no matter what the raven says